today we're going to talk about the
different types of computers the biggest
type of computer we're going to talk
about is a supercomputer which maybe
you've heard of a supercomputer uses a
whole bunch of CPUs and uses something
called parallel processing all of those
CPUs work on the same problem at the
same time the next type we're going to
talk about is a server a server holds
and accesses a bunch of data or programs
our website free code camp is hosted on
a server which stores all that
information next let's talk about a
workstation computer now a workstation
computer just looking at it might look
similar to a personal computer but it
has a bunch more power and is way more
expensive Toy Story was built on
workstation computers now personal
computers by far the most common type of
computers maybe you've heard I'm a Mac
I'm a PC something like they're
different but really this map is still
just a PC it's a it's a personal
computer it's still a book the Mac and a
PC the last type of computer we're going
to talk about is a microcontroller
microcontroller that's the type of tiny
computer you might have in your car that
has a really specialized task and is
really good that one small thing but
it's not like you could use it like a
regular personal computer so just to
review 5,000 computers supercomputer
server workstation PC and
microcontroller